non ce que tu dis toi c'est que tu es
artiste avant d'être Sidé un et que
chaque fois on te sort ça quoi voilà
vous avez déclaré à longueur d'onde
j'aime pas la télé mais j'adore y aller
c'est vrai que je peux pas y passer sans
faire le zapping parce que finalement la
télé est faite pour ne rien dire et moi
j'ai toujours quelque chose à dire voilà
donc voilà j'ai dit ça sur l'homme mais
aujourd'hui je sais pas si c'est arrivé
comme ça
alors aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez à
dire Mano Solo c'est que vous sortez un
disque votre huitième album depuis 1993
ça s'appelle les animals alors au départ
la moitié des morceaux était destinés à
Juliette Gréco mais l'affaire ne sait
pas faite et c'est vous qui les chantez
voilà alors Gréco vous dites quand on
vous dit qu'il y a du sexe et de la
sueur dans votre dans votre album qui
voulait ça voilà c'est Gréco qui
trouvait un peu mignon ce qu'on lui
avait fait jusque jusque là où elle
interrompue dans sa production elle a
dit bon bah tiens ouais fais-moi du son
du
absolument
on s'est rendu compte ce soir faut vous
le dire quand même que Sacha Distel en
fait était dominé nous on le prenait
pour un playboy voire gigolpin un peu
pas du tout en fait que ça soit Juliette
Gréco Jeanne Moreau ou Brigitte Bardot
elle le dominait et elle l'ont planté et
il était très malheureux en fait Sacha
Distel était un sentimentale voilà ce
qu'on a appris ce soir malheureux
malheureux avec les femmes Sacha Distel
malheureux
voilà alors à part ça votre album est un
album assez apaisé vous hurlez moins
qu'avant non bah c'est parce que c'était
pour Juliette ah voilà ouais c'est les
chansons qui sont dans une tonalité que
j'avais fait pour elle quand même j'ai
bien travaillé quand même pour ça aux
grosses voix chaude qui est pas vraiment
la mienne donc là je suis obligé de
chanter comme j'ai pas l'habitude ça me
fait du bien parce que j'en ai marre de
gueuler parce que j'en ai marre de pas
écouter mes disques en fait parce qu'il
me saoule le mec qui chante quoi tu vois
mais il y a aussi une chose c'est
peut-être que vous êtes devenu plus
sociable
que des un bon retour quoi de rester
aigri il faudrait vraiment être con
c'est quoi qui vous a appris à vivre
la réussite en fin de le contact avec
les gens de la reconnaissance
soit pleine en fait c'est ça qui est
important le disent qu'ils sont là pour
ça ce qui est important c'est que
pendant deux heures vraiment je m'éclate
comme un comme un gamin quoi
pleine liberté c'est ça c'est précieux
il y a un morceau qui s'appelle savane
où vous dites je n'ai plus ce sentiment
si violent si méchant non c'est vrai que
au début je montais sur scène
j'en avais absolument rien à [ __ ] de
ce qu'on pouvait penser de MOI quoi
c'était j'avais juste une envie c'était
de mettre mon mes chansons dans la
gueule des gens en vérité c'était un peu
effectivement en cours de route
mon plaisir de monter sur scène et il a
complètement évolué là c'est moi j'ai un
plaisir de monter sur scène parce que je
vais me fondre la gueule avec des gens
qui attendent que ça de moi c'est
complètement différent j'ai plus du tout
envie de leur faire du mal alors il y a
un morceau vous attaqué à la Trinité
travail famille Sarkozy
ça vous inquiète Sarkozy vous vous
pensez que quand même je sais pas
j'arrête pas de penser à tous ces gens
avant les élections qui qui
était persuadé que la droite et la
gauche c'était la même chose on voit
depuis quand même quelques temps que
franchement c'est pas la même chose que
quand on voit des gens qui déboulent au
pouvoir et qui s'attaque qui s'attaquent
à qui au gitan tu vois ils ont
stigmatisé les gitans il y avait même eu
des députés pour dire oui heureusement
bien comment il se paye leur bagnole je
trouve qu'ils ont fait que ça quoi
d'essayer de de trouver des têtes de
turc
comment ils ont fait avec les
intermittents aussi c'est-à-dire que
nous les intermittents on génère de
l'emploi bien plus qu'on est parasite
comment comme cellier a voulu le faire
croire
je trouve ça grave quand même qu'on est
un Sarkozy à l'économie et puis un
Sarkozy au MEDEF ça fait quand même
c'est son frère c'est bon je suis pas
moi type engagé simplement
quand on a de la chance comme moi d'être
un artiste et de rien [ __ ] de ses
journées on peut pas ne pas assister à
ça et avoir envie de le dire quoi d'une
manière ou d'une autre que il serait
peut-être temps que que qu'on se
réveille qu'on arrête de de moutonner
quoi c'est de maintenant
c'est encore une fois une chanson parce
que je dis que je me fais mon petit
grand soir c'est ridicule quoi je suis
tout seul à délirer sur ma chanson avec
laquelle je m'endormais quand j'étais
gamin quoi j'en ai partisans
c'est un peu pathétique d'ailleurs
Benjamin Biolay Bénabar Yann Tiersen
c'est pas trop votre dans les entends
pas si tu veux c'est les mecs qui sucent
pour les vieilles sur la fuges des
histoires de complètement consensuelles
qui mangent pas de pain des petites
historiettes
je sais pas moi
j'entends même pas j'écoute même pas toi
c'est plutôt quoi les Têtes Raides
j'aime bien c'est quelqu'un que je
respecte parce qu'il y a il y a autre
chose que des chansons nièces quoi c'est
c'est tout un univers culturel qui est
qui est sur scène quoi c'est
maintenant solo libération le 24
septembre chronique et les animals sous
la plume de Ludovic Perrin en disant
Mano Solo a tellement annoncé sa mort
que sa survie a aujourd'hui quelque
chose de banal réchapper in extremis
grâce à la trithérapie le chanteur du
sida a progressivement ouvert son propos
au monde conclusion
manque de puissance comme ça je me mets
mon étoile comme ça tout le monde est
content finalement tu sais si tu veux on
peut pas vivre dans ce pays en ayant dit
une fois dans ta vie que tu étais
atteinte d'une maladie sans contre la
ressorte à chaque fois que tu à chaque
fois que tu sors quelque part
effectivement moi je suis éclaboussé
partout je passe quoi j'en ai un peu
plein le cul quoi maintenant je vais
peut-être réagir
à la limite tout le monde va croire que
tiens ça y est on a plutôt aussi quoi
tu n'en parlais plus et d'un seul coup
libération plutôt bien
parce que j'ai dit un jour ouais et
alors
tort il est là depuis 10 ans poursuit
j'en ai plein le cul de dire que ton
disque leur plaisait pas il a fallu que
qu'on introduise l'article par le fait
que moi je suis sentir des sida je sais
pas où il a vu ça ce type mais je sais
pas si tu veux
rien à [ __ ] de lui ici pour moi c'est
l'exemple de toute la presse entière
depuis 10 ans qui me poursuit finalement
je suis une démonstration permanente que
Irène dans ce pays une exclusion
positive si tu veux par exemple c'était
le titre de de mon article de mon droit
de réponse dans Libération aujourd'hui
ils l'ont passé des endroits de réponse
en enlevant tout ce qu'ils ont merdé
bien sûr
et ils ont rajouté le sida dans le titre
moi à mon équipe c'était l'exclusion
positif le titre le titre est devenu
incident comme exclusion vous positif ça
veut plus rien dire si tu veux je sais
pas ce que ça veut dire
exactement tout le monde le sache quoi
c'est ça donc ça c'est le voilà je j'ai
trouvé un truc je moi je vais mettre mon
étoile quoi comme les Juifs
sachez-le quoi OK
que tout le monde est sage quoi
tu as bien foutu l'ambiance
et que chaque fois on ressort ça quoi
voilà et libère action c'est comme ça
je fais des chansons pour Juliette Gréco
je lis dans une dépêche de l'agence de
presse que à MIMO dans une chanson qui
s'appelle jenniferien je parle de ma
séropositivité tu vois mais c'est
n'importe quoi ça devient c'est de toute
façon une information qu'il est
indispensable de donner dès qu'on parle
de Mano Solo donc moi je commence à en
avoir plein QG j'ai cru que cette
démonstration était flagrante et qu'elle
finirait par être comprise de tous mais
finalement non elle est pas flagrante
c'est pour ça que je fais mon petit
cinéma aujourd'hui si tu veux parce que
j'en ai plein le cul aujourd'hui parce
que ça commence à bien faire moi je vis
et finalement ce qu'il y a de paradoxal
finalement c'est que quand ils m'ont cru
le porte-drapeau d'une maladie j'étais
pas malade
aujourd'hui je suis malade j'ai vraiment
autre chose à penser autre chose à
raconter autre chose à aimer dans la vie
et pas me faire chier avec leurs
conneries j'aimerais bien qu'on lâche la
grappe en fait tu en as parlé dans ton
premier album en 93 ça fait quand même
longtemps tu disais j'ai la mort aux
trous ce qui me fout les fois et en 95
si on a parlé une deuxième fois sur la
scène du Bataclan en disant cette phrase
de nouvelle une bonne une mauvaise la
bonne c'est que je suis plus séropositif
la mauvaise c'est que j'ai le sida moi
j'ai le droit d'en parler
j'ai aussi le droit d'être tranquille
mais j'ai le droit de pas être montré du
doigt j'ai le droit de pas que ça figure
pas sur mon front sur ma carte
d'identité tu vois j'ai le droit de ça
j'ai le droit de qu'on fasse attention à
ce que à mes chansons bordel de merde tu
vois qu'une critique le type il a trouvé
que mon album il était pas terrible il a
qu'à le dire je n'ai rien à [ __ ] tu
vois mais pourquoi il a besoin de dire
que ah c'est vachement moins bien que
quand tu vas mieux voilà c'est ça
en plus
ça fait encore penser aux gens que
thérapie on ne meurt pas du sida c'est
ce qui est une connerie monumentale
aujourd'hui alors que les gens arrêtent
d'en mettre des capotes parce qu'il
s'imaginent qu'on s'en sort comme avec
trois aspirines tu vois c'est à tous les
niveaux c'est n'importe c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi quoi et par exemple aussi
il s'intéressant quand on voit que dans
mon droit de réponse je parlais d'un
article moi j'avais parlé effectivement
du sida pour demander qu'on me foute la
paix et que si on voulait parler
docteur tu vois que quelque chose à
raconter moi j'ai rien à dire tu vois et
c'était un article que j'avais cité dans
mon droit de réponse pour dire ça ils
ont enlevé ce bout où je parle de ça et
Perrin refait un droit de réponse au
droit de réponse en disant tu vois dans
cet article tu en as parlé c'est
carrément une manipulation mais c'est
démentiel tu vois c'est c'est à dire il
faut absolument en plus qui c'est le
dernier mot tu vois c'est quelque chose
de
je sais pas pour moi c'est céder le
pénis ça va pas chercher plus loin quoi
c'est stigmatisé en permanence un
individu et moi je supporte pas parce
que je pense que j'ai quand même autre
chose à vendre que cette collé c'est
depuis 10 ans je raconte autre chose aux
gens sinon il viendrait pas me voir
franchement il faudrait qu'on pourra
acheter le 10 d'un mec qui parle de sida
depuis 10 ans en plus il crève pas alors
qu'est-ce que vous fait chier quoi tu
vois c'est un peu ça quoi tu vois il
fait chier maintenant solo de pas crever
quoi tu vois si je te souhaite
mais c'est bien tu as mis des choses au
point là ouais j'en profite
alors
Mano Solo on va on va revenir à
l'artiste on va revenir on va revenir à
l'artiste on va revenir au poète avec
une interview en un mot
[Musique]
quel est le mot qui sonne le mieux dans
la langue française pour toi
Pontault-Combault quel est le mot que tu
préfères entendre en anglais
Fuck You quel est le mot que tu n'as
jamais dit à une femme
quel est le mot que tu n'as jamais dit à
un homme
C quel est le mot que tu ne voudrais pas
entendre dans la bouche d'un enfant
sécurité de l'emploi
quel est le mot qui pourrait te faire
tout quitter
quel est le mot qui revient le plus
souvent dans tes chansons la vie quel
est le mot qui revient le plus souvent
dans ta tête
les sentiments quel est le mot qui
revient le plus souvent quand on parle
de toi
quel est le mot qui te rappelle ton
meilleur souvenir
premier Olympia ça c'était bien quel est
le mot qui résume tes faiblesses dans la
vie les chiite
quel mot qui te donne envie de gagner tu
as tout perdu
quel est le mot qui te donne envie de
pleurer
Ludovic
quel est le mot que tu voudrais qu'on
grave sur ta pierre tombale vive la
révolution et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu